we were at gun store earlier you know
you got the uh
the buffalo kids gallery which was a
very impressive place
that should fly that [ __ ] is crazy um
but we were kind of making fun of the
fact that uh there's been this
narrative about you know you benny and
him kind of
growing apart drifting apart you know et
cetera
and how funny it was like did those
conversations that happen online
do they ever like get frustrating
because it's obviously
not the case you know what i mean like
is it ever somewhere you're just like yo
what the [ __ ] like
people are bored or what honestly
you know i'm saying
you know they people love griselda man
like
you know this griselda [ __ ] man this
thing we built
we ain't even see it being well i knew
without
you know it was gonna be special and
that was gonna be like
you know what i'm saying you know i knew
it was gonna work and i knew cause i
knew i've always believed in what was
bringing to the table and the talent
but i don't even think me and wes knew
what this [ __ ] was gonna be when we
started this [ __ ] up you know what i'm
saying and um
some fans love us man more than we know
sometimes you know what i'm saying and
um
so yes concerns man genuine concerns and
questions from fans like
you know when they see certain little
[ __ ] from the outside looking in that's
probably not the norm
from what they what they're used to you
know what i'm saying
and you know a couple of my tweets
that i i put out there probably didn't
help things
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah they
might have thrown a log on the fire
yeah and um
you know but the truth of the matter is
we
we have grown apart man you know i'm
saying like we ain't
you know what i'm saying we're not
really the young boys no more
you know just hanging out and you know
chasing a dream
and we all like like grown grown-ass men
with families and you know
responsibilities
and people to take care of and we have
everybody got their own brands and other
things that they
you know expanding and and and and
[ __ ] with two that you know
time is is very limited you know what i
mean
you might not see us together all the
time you might not hear us on the same
album all the time [ __ ] might just
genuinely didn't have time to get the
verse done
right [ __ ] might just genuinely didn't
have time to pull up to the show
right it just you know i mean like we
getting you know
man this gazelle is getting bigger than
what we even would have thought so
you know i could see where that you know
them you know
the questions and concerns come from
from like the fans and [ __ ]
well i'm gonna keep it a thousand two
like this is real [ __ ] check
real [ __ ] time like some of my tweets
and [ __ ] probably didn't help
um he's there you know their concerns
right right right right and the funny
[ __ ] is like some of my tweets
was like all of them [ __ ] is really just
like some of them just was like
just like verses i wrote like bars
right that i written and you know
wasn't even nothing that i thought in my
mind like
would get taken that way right right
right right because i'm not no
internet dude like i don't even really
right i'm not the guy that's just going
to just be
having twitter like just going crazy on
twitter like
you know what you know we we
family in real life so that don't go
away
don't go away forever yeah i think too
like
it's unfair for fans to not expect you
and benny to grow your own brands
and like you know what i'm saying like
and and to level up your own [ __ ]
right because at the end of the day like
like you said it in a
in on a record where you were like uh
yeah west owns the land but i did the
construction but now you got your own
land
and you do and you know what i'm saying
and it's drum work you know what i mean
and benny's got bsf
and that don't mean that rick hyde ain't
fam
and you know everybody's everybody's in
the next room
you know what i'm saying i met rick with
you for the first time
yeah so you know what i'm saying so it's
like i just think like i think a lot of
uh
hip-hop fans are conditioned that our
favorite groups never last
and i know you guys aren't necessarily a
group but you know we came up and
wu-tang had their issues and and dip
said obviously
you know like a lot of our favorite
groups didn't necessarily you know
last as long as we like but i think that
with you guys i'm not sure that that's
the case i just think it's like you said
it's just natural gross
natural growth you guys are all popping
as [ __ ] all busy as [ __ ]
we have the businesses we have artists
that we got to work with
and get them you know off and running
and all that [ __ ] and
you know it's just it's just it's just
business it's just life we grown man
but you know it's just interesting too
because like
you know we never we we're not a group
you know what i'm saying
right we was a group like when shenegan
was alive we was asking you guys are a
label
yeah but we turned into a label like
everybody was their own entity they
artists like benny was his wife
[Music]
but hey shout out y'all got nominated
for best hip-hop group at the bt awards
though it's crazy
yeah not being a group yeah being a
group
yeah just we just all collabed on the
tape
you know what i'm saying so i didn't
even think about that like that that's
the fact
that's crazy right like we weren't even
a group we got nominated for over the
years
we just collapsed on some records and
you know
but you know i mean we're together
stronger
and we always going to be strong dog and
you know them that's family bro and this
you know what i mean they own an album
we got an incredible record on
final final song in the album right i
think it's the last record
i look at the track listen today i think
i think it might be the last one